i
vladimir tiene a cargo la tarea de
mantener a punto los tres carros
cisterna de los servicios de emergencia
ucranianos en back mud una labor
arriesgada en tiempos de guerra las
tropas rusas están un radio de 10 km y
atacan permanentemente con misiles de
cohetes la ciudad
nos hemos acostumbrado
cuando tenemos una amenaza directa y
tenemos que trabajar en la calle
nos ponemos nuestros equipos de
protección los tres viviendas
la responsabilidad de estos hombres va
más allá de ayudar en los momentos de
crisis también apoyan a la sociedad
civil que se ha negado a marcharse a
pesar de la insistencia de las
autoridades para que la población evacúe
en bakú todavía permanece el 30 por
ciento de sus 73 mil habitantes
hacemos una lista previa de la gente que
está necesitada de ayuda y les damos una
hora de recogida tratamos de hacerlo lo
más pronto posible para evitar las
conglomeraciones
a la vuelta a la esquina estas
edificaciones son la evidencia del
peligro que representa salir a la calle
es difícil de evaluar la moral de los
habitantes pero lo que puedo ver de mi
parte es que cada día más gente irritada
la gente que está cansada por este
continuo estado de guerra gran parte de
la población que permanece apoya su
supervivencia en estos paquetes
humanitarios y dinar gente a uno de los
últimos supermercados abiertos sus
empleados son algunos de los pocos que
conservan su trabajo pero no están
exentos de las dificultades económicas
la gente no tiene trabajo
muchos viven de donaciones
estos paquetes nos hacen felices es una
verdadera ayuda
irina permanecerá en back mode hasta que
sus jefes mantengan abierto supermercado
pero trabajan con dificultad la ciudad
no sólo vive escasez de muchos productos
los precios han disparado se suma que la
electricidad se corta permanentemente
pero temen que lo peor podría llegar en
invierno iuris el director de los
servicios de emergencia su calendario se
detuvo el 23 de febrero al igual que sus
vidas
todos aquí entienden que si no son ellos
o no hay nadie que pueda socorrer a los
ciudadanos
está en su casa en sus ciudades
y todos sus amigos y familiares están
aquí seguimos
claramente esa es una gran motivación
para ellos
durante estos cinco meses las visiones
de su equipo se han multiplicado
artur el subdirector del grupo va camino
a comprobar una llamada de emergencia
nos dirigimos a un edificio donde nos
informaron que había un objeto explosivo
para eliminarlo primero necesitamos
confirmar la información identificarlo y
más tarde enviar a los hombres que lo
desactivan
una explosión lo obliga a detenerse en
el camino
la ciudad está nuevamente bajo ataque
esto es la guerra puede pasar de todo en
cualquier momento algunas veces en la
noche y otras veces en el día
buen apoyo y navas de donde a partir su
padre ha perforado no estoy en pocos
días pero ahora con el frío
les informa que uno los lugares atacados
no están muy lejos de su centro de
operaciones
artur no considera seguro acercarse a la
base de sí dar una vuelta por la ciudad
para comprobar el alcance de lo sucedido
[Aplausos]
en este edificio el cohete alcanzó un
recinto residencial una mujer mayor que
caminaba por el parque con su marido fue
alcanzada por las esquirlas del cohete
los médicos de urgencia tratan de salvar
las dos piernas
metros más adelante otro cohete cayó
cerca del instituto de arte de la ciudad
los estragos se extienden al resto de la
calle donde minutos después los
habitantes se han lanzado a limpiarla
todos los maestros vinieron y están
tratando de salvar la escuela
porque realmente la mano
desafortunadamente pasó esta desgracia
no sabemos por qué sucedió
finalmente artur se une a sus hombres se
apagan un fuego a las afueras de la
ciudad
un cohete alcanzó este garaje que
guardaba un carro en su interior
anoche tenis
estos hombres acusan a los periodistas
de haber propiciado el ataque
artur les explica que la prensa lleva
todo el día con él y que llegaron
después de que el fuego estaba prendido
no es extraño que algunos de los
habitantes culpen a las fuerzas
ucranianas de los ataques esta es una
región donde la población está dividida
y un sector apoya al separatismo
pero estos hombres tratan de no darle
importancia está su ciudad y su misión
es ayudar a todos más allá de la
política